foreign
[Music]
hey you guys doing another tomes of
Terror book review sorry I haven't been
doing as many of these uh lately but any
of you guys that have been around for a
long time know that you know I actually
ended up having to get a full-time job
so I don't have as much time to read
books and I also don't have as much time
to make videos about them either but I
am going to try and you know keep up
with them and maybe at least do you know
one a month or even more if I can uh
manage it
so this book right here
um now I'm a graphic designer by trade
have been for about a quarter Century at
this point because I'm old as
um so maybe I don't know so maybe it's
like a little self-serving of me to say
that book covers are really really
important you guys you know just because
I'm biased in that regard because like I
said I'm I'm a graphic designer that
doesn't mean that the statement isn't
absolutely true for example uh the book
that I'm talking about today uh the 2020
novel the house that fell from the sky
uh by Patrick Delaney it was actually
the cover design that was a significant
component in why I particularly chose to
read it like while I was scrolling
through all the Kindle unlimited options
um now I'll admit the Intriguing title
the house that fall from this guy that's
a great title
um that kind of like hooked me into but
the cover design is
is chef's kiss it's it's really really
good
um the designer by the way is named Ross
nishler nishler or nishler I'm not
really sure how you pronounce his last
name so I apologize for that but I
definitely wanted to give him a shout
out because I I really really like the
cover of this it's dynamite now I I'm
gonna say that even though I I feel like
the story within the covers didn't quite
live up to the awesomeness like of the
exterior package but it was still a
pretty solidly entertaining read for
people who are maybe into haunted house
stories but that have like kind of a
cosmic horror twist to them so the house
that fell from this guy it revolves
around four friends who I think are kind
of like all in their late 20s early 30s
type of age bracket now at times the
dialogue between them kind of sounds
more like discussions had by teenagers
perhaps
um this isn't necessarily A criticism by
the way um you know I'm 50 years old and
I still have conversations like this
because you know I'm kind of immature
and I'm not really shamed of that fact I
did see that some reviewers say that the
book read like a y a I don't really
concur with that assessment overall um
it is like a pretty easy kind of breezy
read with wisecracking characters who
are constantly snarking at one another
but that was like a big thing that I saw
a lot of people mentioned in their
reviews that they thought the characters
came across more like teenagers than
people in their late 20s like I said
that didn't bother me but I'm just
saying that that's something that a lot
of people notice so if that's gonna
bother you then maybe the characters
will bother you in this novel as well so
our main protagonist is Scarlett Van
Tassel she is a somewhat successful I
kind of feel like horror YouTuber like
she talks about horror and like reviews
horror movies and stuff like that it's
gonna you know kind of like what I do
but she has found herself kind of I
guess sort of like a drift in life at 29
years of age now she grew up in this
city named called winterview but I guess
she always sort of like had bigger
aspirations she always like dreamed of
bigger and better things now at some
point a few years prior to the events of
the novel she actually ran off with this
guy that she met she didn't really run
off with him but like they started a
relationship and then like she went to
another town with him his name was Luke
and he was supposedly like the big love
of her life and everything and she
started college and did all this other
stuff
but not too long after that
I guess that both her and Luke sort of
realized and I think Luke realized it
before she did that Scarlett was kind of
only doing what she thought she was
supposed to be doing like in regards to
adulting and she was constantly like
subsuming her own identity to Luke's I
guess like in a way it's like he's like
did you really want to come to this town
did you really want to go to college and
do this that and the other you're not
really doing what you want to do and
you're kind of like losing you know the
the person that I fell in love with
because now you're just like doing what
I what I want to do and he didn't really
want to be responsible for that so he
actually kind of like gently breaks it
off with her he's like you know you you
need to go back to being you instead of
just like an adjunct to me you know what
I mean which you know that was like
pretty cool of him to do but uh she
didn't really think so at the time but
she did kind of like realize it later on
so after they break up she kind of like
goes back to her hometown like with her
tail between her legs a little bit and
she moves back in with her dad now she's
also been contemplating ending her
YouTube channel even though she is
apparently has like you know millions of
fans and it used to be something she
really quite enjoyed but at the
beginning she just feels like at a loss
and she doesn't really know what to do
with her life so she's just kind of like
I'm gonna to make a video and tell
everybody that I'm quitting or whatever
now also factoring into the plot
is Scarlet's brother Tommy who seems
about the same age you know roughly uh
now he was actually an aspiring
professional baseball player like he was
going to be in the MLB and everything
like that and he had to end up foregoing
his dreams after like this injury ended
his Sports career which factors into the
plot like later on uh you also have
Tommy's girlfriend and Scarlett's former
best friend whose name is Hannah and
she's actually been having a really
really hard time uh dealing with the
fairly recent death of her mother his
name was Eve and then there's also
Jackson who is a bartender and
Scarlett's close friend now he's sort of
contending with a very very strained
relationship with his father who I think
is like the winter view chief of police
or something like that and he's a real
hard ass type like you know nothing that
Jackson ever does is good enough and you
know there there's just seems like no
love loss there
um he also seems to have like some
unrequited romantic feelings for
Scarlett which she doesn't seem to be
all that aware of because she kind of
just sees him as more of like a buddy
so all three of these other characters
also Harbor I don't want to lean too
hard into this but they kind of Harbor
maybe like differing levels of
resentment towards Scarlet for like
taking off with Luke like this random
dude without really saying goodbye to
like her friends that she's known
forever
um Hannah's feelings of Abandonment I
feel like are you know very easily the
most pronounced because she feels Like
Scarlett threw away like this lifelong
friendship for just some Rando and was
you know hence not there to help her
through a grief like after her mother
died
now once Scarlet comes back into town
like at the beginning of the book though
um it seems like the four of them still
kind of like hang out and try to resolve
their differences but they do kind of
like snipe at one another about these
sort of simmering resentments now what
about this house that fell from the sky
of the title you might be asking well
we'll get to that although I will warn
you that even though a house does indeed
fall from the sky as the title uh
promises you know fairly early on in the
story it then kind of like simmers on
the back burner for like a really long
time while a bunch of this character
stuff plays out like these relationship
kind of things how you feel about that
is kind of like up to you but it was by
far the main criticism that I saw in
other reviews of this novel other than
the characters seem like teenagers but
that you know some people didn't really
care about that but the main criticism I
saw in other reviews was that it took
too long to get into the actual house
and yeah I do admit that to an extent I
agree with that this is a long ass book
it's about 528 Pages at least the Kindle
version which is what I read and I think
that the thing was more than half over
before the heroes even set foot in the
house so just know going in that this is
essentially like a character study or is
like more about the relationships
between the four core characters for the
first 250 300 Pages something like that
with just the promise of this house kind
of lurking around in the background so
as I mentioned not too long into the
story The titular house uh actually does
come crashing down just randomly in the
middle of downtown winter view one day
and everyone is completely and
understandably quite baffled by this
development uh the house looks all kind
of like Gothic and spooky it's a big
like Mansion kind of thing it's very
spooky looking and it soon becomes clear
that something about it is
um let's call it otherworldly okay now
the authorities they kind of rope it off
after trying and failing to get inside
but on the handful of occasions that
someone does manage to get into the
house or get past the House's defenses I
guess
um there's actually like a rival horror
YouTuber guy that is trying to get in
there for his channel and like a rookie
cop who gets in there they basically
kind of like go insane and kill
themselves like basically within seconds
of emerging from the house so the house
actually becomes
kind of like a worldwide media sensation
which obviously it would in real life
and it subsequently gets purchased by
this kind of shady conglomerate known as
the crow Corporation now after all of
this stuff happens and like there's a
big media hype and everything like that
which like I said is kind of in the
background or like on the fringes of the
main story with the four characters
um at actually a year in Winter view
goes by and the house is pretty much
reduced to like I said kind of like
background noise like the main
characters sort of talk about it every
now and then of course and uh you know
because it's kind of a big thing in
their town and there's concern that
Hannah in particular might be becoming
really obsessed with it but overall
um you know Scarlett Tommy and Jackson
are just kind of going about their
regular somewhat dead-end Lives having
conversations about the house sometimes
but mainly about other things and about
their past and stuff like that but then
the crow corporation which that is one
minor criticism is I kind of wish more
had been gone into about the crow
Corporation you don't really find out
hardly anything about them and I don't
know if he's planning on like another
book like where he's gonna go more into
that or any but you know that's just
like a minor little quibble and I just
thought I would mention it but uh at
some point like the crow Corporation
announces kind of like a Willy Wonka
style contest and it's like this Lottery
where they send out tickets to everybody
in Winter view So the lucky people whose
numbers get drawn will be allowed to
enter the house on Halloween night if
they can survive and if they can survive
the entire night there and come out
unscathed which so far has not happened
um they will receive one million dollars
each in prize money
now obviously uh everyone kind of wants
to do it but kind of not because the
house also seems to have like a little
bit of
uh like bad energy bad mojo that kind of
like leaks out like you know so the
nearer you are to the house like the
more kind of up you feel and um
you know people that have been in there
like I said they either like they
committed suicide or they went insane or
whatever
so it will probably not surprise anyone
since they are reading this book that
our four protagonists are the ones who
end up going in now the way this ends up
happening is a little bit convoluted
because Hannah whose mother actually
left her a considerable Fortune like you
know buying a big mansion that
is kind of like empty but she just like
lives in there and Grieves kind of thing
um she essentially buys her way into the
house because she's convinced that her
Dead Mother's spirit I guess is like
waiting for her in there like I said
she's kind of become obsessed with it
after this development the other three
kind of feel obligated to go with her
because you know she's their best friend
and they just want to make sure that
she's going to be okay and that like
nothing terrible is going to happen
because they try to like convince her
not to because they're like you know
you're gonna die in there pretty much
but she is absolutely dead set so
they're like well then we have to go
with her obviously so uh yeah that's the
thing it's like by this time pretty much
everybody is damn sure that the house
probably came from some other dimension
and is you know almost certainly bad
news for anybody that goes in there um
and they're probably not gonna come out
alive or sane so at a little past the
halfway mark of the novel I feel like
our main characters along with a fifth
character uh who's kind of like this
elusive magician whose name is Vincent
velodex he's another character that I
wish had been in the story more like
he's kind of mentioned in the first part
of it like oh he was this famous
musician magician like the the most
famous guy like from this town or
whatever and he like disappeared you
know what I mean but then he kind of
like pops back up and you know some
people thought the house was like a
trick that he was doing like to you know
it was like this whole thing but I kind
of wish like he was hardly in it like he
was just mentioned in the first part but
then he shows up and he's one of the
ones that's gonna go into the house with
them
once they go into the house pretty much
all lovecraftian hell breaks loose now
we never really learned much about The
house's history other than just kind of
like a few very rudimentary details
um and we never really grasp fully like
what the house is exactly like I said
it's very much a cosmic horror type of
situation but I will say that kind of
The Saga of the four of them or the five
of them rather like inside the house is
pretty cool regardless so there's like
lots of trippy descriptions of Eldritch
Horrors and so forth
um as the house it essentially seems to
be like trying to break the minds of
everybody that enters it so there are
also a lot of flashbacks in this part of
the book as well as the characters like
become separated and they sort of like
fall foul of The house's uh you know
charms I guess or like what it's trying
to do like it's trying to drive them
insane like showing them horrible things
and I will say that although some of the
flashbacks
um you know are relevant to like what's
happening
um you know particularly how they ended
up meeting Vincent velodex like the
magician and like how he factors in and
things like that and how Tommy uh you
know hurt his arm and stuff some of it
not so much um you know they're
interesting but some of them don't
really factor into the plot all that
what all that much so I do kind of wish
that the novel had been trimmed for
length which is a tad
um because some of the background
character stuff doesn't really factor
that much into the larger plot like I
said it's interesting it's all character
background stuff but I feel like it
would have been
you know better if some of it had been
trimmed out because it didn't seem like
it was all that important that said
though uh the characters are actually
like pretty well drawn and I admit that
I did become like really emotionally
invested in their fate so like when bad
happened to them like I did get
upset and things like that so you know
that's that's good like that's a that's
a sign that I did actually like care
about the characters but um in spite of
that I did kind of wish that the balance
of the story had kind of been tipped
more in the direction of like the creepy
crazy house stuff that was going on and
kind of Less in scenes of you know the
characters just talking about like the
Before Time like before Scarlett left
and before all this other stuff and like
all the relationship kind of stuff some
of that was important like for you to
get emotionally invested in the
characters but I don't think it needed
to be as much in there and I kind of
wish that they had done more with the
house or they had gone into the house
earlier because one I mean once you get
in the house like the sequences inside
the house are really really vividly
described and some of the imagery is
like legit scary now I don't think that
I would call this book overly scary as a
whole
um but some of the imagery is kind of
like disturbing in a very Cosmic horror
sort of way like it's sort of like
The Haunting of Hill House like more
than Netflix series than the novel I'm
talking about where it's just kind of
like more about the character stuff and
then like the the Paranormal or the
weird is kind of like in the
background or like around the margins
um and it kind of reminded me I don't
know if I'd go so far in this direction
but it's a little bit like Silent Hill I
don't know if that's it's just a little
bit you know what I mean
um and it's just kind of like all
matched up together with sort of like
tripping on a low dose of acid type of
thing
um because like while they're inside the
house essentially time becomes
meaningless and the characters kind of
go through things where they seemingly
die and then like return to life in a
different spot in the mansion with
little to no memory of what happened or
how long they've been in there and
things like that so the Mansion is sort
of like purgatorial in that sense I
guess but as I mentioned I kind of wish
that more of the House's history and
construction and like its Essence had
been explained and I kind of wish that
we'd gone more a little bit more into
what the crow Corporation was how they
knew about the house
um why they offered this particular uh
contest why they wanted people to go in
there like some of the people that they
found when they were in there like what
was that about I kind of want wish there
had been more of that but you know I
mean to be fair the characters in the
novel like from their point of view
wouldn't have known what the was up
at this place so maybe it was better to
leave it mysterious because you're
seeing things from their perspective and
they didn't know anything about the
house they were just kind of
experiencing it as they experienced it
so overall I found this like a really
enjoyable read now I will note that it
took me way longer than usual to get
through it
um I don't know if that was necessarily
because it was really long or I wasn't
into it or something like that I think
it was more because I was kind of
obligated to read it like on my phone
like in short chunks over you know a
week or so of like lunch hour hours from
work so if that's not really conducive
to Total immersion in the story when
you're just reading things like on a
tiny phone like in hour-long chunks and
I couldn't really like to fully devote
like a day to it or anything like that
um I will say I really really like the
descriptions of the house and the sort
of like nightmarish journey of the
characters as they explored it and I
really did like appreciate the time that
was spent building up the characters
backstories
um and you know each of them had their
own arc and their own problems and I
thought that was good
um but that said I kind of wish the
protagonists had gone into the house
earlier like I said and more had been
revealed about The house's true nature
maybe and about what the crow
corporation's deal was I also would have
liked Vincent validax the magician to
have factored into the story more
throughout like it would have been cool
like in the first half of the book like
if we had maybe seen like a few scenes
from his point of view but maybe I don't
know maybe Patrick Delaney the author
maybe he wanted it to be like hey
surprise like the guy just turns up in
the middle even though he'd just been
mentioned like beforehand so it was more
like a surprise
um you know so I guess I can kind of see
that uh as well but I mean he was really
interesting he was maybe I mean I really
liked Scarlett the main character but I
think Victor velodex was probably like
the most interesting character and I
kind of wanted to know more about him
like what his deal was because you
didn't really find out much about his
past or why he turned up at this
particular time or anything like I mean
you do kind of find out but you know it
just didn't seem like enough
um the characters like I mentioned did
also read significantly younger than
people in their late 20s but really like
I said that didn't really bother me all
that much
um you know they were all kind of like
horror nerds and stuff like that which
I'm that too so it's really didn't read
as all that weird to me
um there was also kind of like this sort
of I really liked this sort of small
town wistfulness Vibe like to them and
like to the characters uh and to the
story because they were just like the
characters I feel like were just
beginning to realize that all of these
big aspirations that they had as
teenagers and young adults we're
probably never going to come to pass and
life wasn't like working out the way
that they wanted and I thought that gave
the story like a little bit of depth in
that regard so if you like sort of like
lovecraftian type stories because this
does have like a lovecraftian bent to it
um and if you're willing to kind of be
patient with a book that is very
intensely character focused and
relationship focused rather than maybe
horror Focus for the first large portion
of the story like until they actually go
into the house then you know it's free
on Kindle unlimited uh if you have a
subscription like you know maybe give it
a whirl it was actually a fantastic
story concept I really liked the idea
um and even though it didn't quite live
up to its sort of like amazing premise
um I still had a really good time with
it and I was pretty satisfied with the
way that it ended now there is actually
another a second book which I think is
called Silver's Hollow and it's not
super long it's only like it's more like
Novella length and it's sort of set in
the same universe as this I think but I
don't think it's like a sequel or
anything like at least I haven't read it
but I went and looked at like the
description and it doesn't look like the
same characters or anything like that
but I just thought I would mention it
because Silver's Hollow is another town
that factors into this book so I guess
he's doing like an extended Mythos type
with these same towns where he's setting
all these stories in the same towns but
he's written some other books too but I
just thought I would mention that one I
don't think it's a sequel like I said it
didn't sound like it but apparently it's
kind of set in it's the same universe or
the same town or something like that so
that will do it for this tomes of Terror
book review uh please like share and
comment if you enjoy this content and I
will see you guys again on the next one
bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]